hello good day how are you it's time
again to revisit five nights at freddy's
i'm hungry
and that's awfully convenient because
this game in the five nights at freddy's
series is all about crunching and
munching and bunching of bones
i actually haven't eaten yet today i'm
very hungry food is on the way but don't
worry about me because we have even more
five nights at freddy's to revisit and
this one is interesting because i
remember that this one
i i'm putting quotes here but i'm not
actually like reinforcing the quotes
this one answered questions right this
one
gave an answer to a lot of the questions
that a lot of people had right
and people weren't terribly
happy about it they weren't unhappy it
was just a little confusing this is
where the lore started to get a little
convoluted because it all spawned from a
concept right a concept that all of this
could take place
in a child's dream at least that's what
i remember uh coming out of this now i
didn't read any of the books because
about this time is when the books
started coming out i haven't read any of
them i haven't even watched matpat's
videos of lore on the books i haven't
done any of that
i ain't got time for that what i do have
time for is to play this game
and revisit the memories of what was
trying to be the scary version of it not
really like scary in that the others
weren't scary they were scary but this
one actually had a more horrific design
of the animatronics they had huge teeth
they had like all this like crazy
aggressive features whereas like five
nights at freddy's 2 you look at the toy
versions they're clearly like toys you
look at five nights at freddy's one
they're not made horrifically like not
only the animatronics up until i'd say
three were made to be any sort of
horrific this one was trying to be
horrific effective i think so but
the question is like does that make it
scarier and also is that even the point
of these games
but anyway
let me get into this it has been
a while since i played this it has been
quite a while five days until the party
of what i thought was
the bite of 87
but it turns out it might not have been
that uh people have been kicking around
the concept of the bite of 83. i don't
know what the bite of 83 is i don't even
remember hearing about the bite of 83
when i was talking about the bite of 87.
i just got an answer about the bite of
87 why am i gonna consider the bite of
83 because i don't know the difference
between either of them
was that the bite of 87 might have been
it might have been i think that quote is
from my video of this game i do believe
some like was that the bite of 87 i'm
pretty sure that was this one
i'm not 100 sure but
this
is the bite of 87
or not or maybe it's not anyway what did
he do this time i don't know he locked
you in your room again don't be scared
i'm here with you oh right this is all
about the crying child
the whole concept
of the crying child these are my friends
this is my dresser this is my bed that's
my
other friend
please
please
[Music]
please
yeah
so
this one actually uh because
i just got done playing five nights at
freddy's 3 right so that one was super
interesting because it it had this
different mechanic of just trying to
lure an animatronic away from you and i
was getting back into the mechanics of
it now this one is more of a return to
form but this one takes a lot of
listening
and that was
potentially bad for my ears at a point
because you have to like listen to a
super quiet sound and then if you get it
wrong big loud
roar in your ear which
was very loud but i forget if i'm
supposed to do something here
up there i needed to knock
three more times and then i would fall
into a ball and cry
tomorrow is another day
i feel like i've seen this scene before
but only because other indie horror
games have kind of emulated that and not
saying that this is the first one to
ever do that sure there but tons of
retro stuff
okay
flick mouse downward to look behind you
that's right
closed doors hold shift uh flash like
this okay i need these tips up right now
because i don't remember a goddamn thing
of how to do this
but also
it kind of was the first one
that gave you some kind of a movement
you know what i mean
it really did
and there are no cameras
listen carefully if you hear breathing
hold the door shut if you do not hear
breathing then use your flashlight right
that's the tough part that is the very
tough part
because it can get
real troublesome
and i can't remember if you can die
see the thing is i don't remember what
the breathing sounds like
i don't remember it from just the sounds
of the the wind
i remember you have to clear
the little freddies off of your bed
it is
terrifying this one in particular
did i used to do that i think i used to
do that when i played this before i
would run to it
i would run to a door and just
see you got the sounds of like the road
and
car sounds outside and i don't
necessarily remember what
okay i'm going to keep those tips up
there for a little longer just because i
want to remember
i don't want to have to
die
it's like you would think that as a kid
you would just keep the doors shut
not open them ever again
and then just go on with your life and
go to bed
but no
i forget what all the signs are i forget
what everything that i need to do is i
mean i think it's just this right
what is that and i don't think i have a
flashlight battery this time
mom
so you in the kitchen mom
i think they did uh scott did a patch
later on after the release
that increased the sound of the
breathing
but i haven't heard the breathing yet so
i don't exactly know what the breathing
is so i'm kind of left on my own
it's unsettling right because before oh
my god
hello
because i haven't heard the breathing
yet and and it's been so long since i
played this that i
don't necessarily know exactly what i'm
looking for
oh wait
there were flowers there did you just
see that there were flowers there i
think i've seen that before
but that was weird
what did i just see hello
did it did i just see something
something was like right there
oh i'm getting itchy
i don't like it
yeah cause i remember that this
oh they are here on the first night oh
good hi
okay that's not good
[Music]
okay
i don't like it i don't like that
i don't like this
it's just that they can get you you know
that's it that's all it ever is
it's just the thinking that something's
under your bed at night
this is literally what it is
oh yeah it's been a while
oh my god
okay all right we're good we're good
[Music]
starting to get the hang of the controls
again
don't check the closet why wouldn't i
check the closet
isn't that kind of a fundamental
part isn't that a fundamental part of
the game
i feel like that's a fundamental part of
i'll turn up the volume if you want
your funeral when it gets jump scary
i can't tell if it's the wind or the
breathing
that's fine
why but why though
why wouldn't i check the closet why why
wouldn't i do that
i physically can't turn up the volume
anymore that's got to be on your end
yeah you're just going to have to crank
it you get in the same boat as me
okay we got through the first night and
we only saw
this much of chica which is good and in
celebration of this i've got a surprise
for you a special prize because you
helped me get through the first night
you can claim your
prize through the link in the
description below it'll take you to
something very special that you're
definitely gonna like i guarantee it
you're gonna like it i know he's hiding
again
who who's hiding
these are my friends
he won't stop until you find him i don't
know who you're talking about
hello
there's a lot of chuckling going on over
here
over there over where
oh
my god
well
such is life i suppose such is life
fun with plushtrap oh right
right
this is crazy that it's skipping two
hours i forget how to
i forget how to do this right there was
a trick to it
not being spicy enough
i'm not gonna get this
he's not moving
i forget if he makes a sound when he
moves he's not going to move
oh come on
hey
okay he moved okay he moved he moved
okay i'm not gonna get it
[Music]
oh i missed it by that much
oh boy
dude
but there was no sound
look
am i crazy there was no sound
where did the where'd the sound go
what
am i deaf
have i gone deaf what happened
what happened the sound's gone
what
all right hang on everybody
hold on
uh let me get this fixed i guess
uh one moment please i guess i gotta
restart that
um
technical difficulties you know they're
just oh man
can you believe it
uh but don't worry guys
i think i got this
yeah
perfect all right this will definitely
be
oh yeah here it is
[Music]
all right let me just oh no
[Music]
correct that's not right yeah that's my
[ __ ] that's not right at all the
invincible
i mean it's our ship this is this is the
captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
this is your trailer to in
i got it confused guys i got it confused
sorry i'm sorry i'll get this
straightened out right away i just can't
seem to figure out one more thing
man i can't believe it
it's up to the
i haven't captain
us down yet
all right there we go
sorry guys that wasn't it that was not
it
that's not it
that is a loud ad yeah that's loud
yeah
all right i'm restarted
hold on hold on i have no idea i
actually don't know why the sound cut
out i literally have no idea
there it is okay we got sound again all
right let's continue that boop
we have no clue
[Music]
oh skip buttons in the description it's
that uh link down there if you click on
that it'll it'll skip all right hold on
all right
i don't know
what's going to be the deal here
knight 2 is clearly going to be harder
but i haven't heard
a single peep yet i haven't heard a peep
oh
i'm not gonna like this am i
i'm not gonna like this
i'm assuming the clanging of plates is
chica much like before
much like before it must just be chica
right
so that means chica
is on the way
[Music]
it's weird not having a
camera right
i do find that
uncomfortable
i don't know what the
i don't know i don't know why i don't
know
i really don't know
i don't know if i'm supposed to check
that
this is actually
it's actually nerve-wracking coming back
to this one more than the other oh my
god
is nerve-wracking
it's
especially three three was like ooh kind
of creepy this one's just
nerve-wracking because it entirely
hinges on the idea of the unknown right
and darkness and
waiting for something to jump out at you
which is like
you know
am i clear is it clear is it clear
oh
god
oh god
oh my god
yeah sniff yeah
good god
all right
oh what do i do
what do i do
i don't know i don't
i don't know
oh
oh
so what just uh happened in the closet
because something happened
okay
oh this is bad
[Music]
i
don't like it
this is legitimately nerve-wracking
oh hi
that's nice i don't remember if i'm
supposed to shut the door on that one or
like
keep it you know
oh my god i hear i hear stippy steps
oh i didn't hear breathing i didn't hear
breathing
right in here breathing
i didn't hear it
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
all right
well
that is uh wake up
listen i told you you all were like oh
it's so quiet and then oh it's so loud
and then oh it's so quiet i told you
this is just the way it be man
this is the way it be
anyway
let's try that again
i mean it's it's kind of crazy just i'm
going to turn the volume back down
because that was
loud
just a little bit though because i need
to be able to hear it that's a thing
right i just got to be able to hear it
i just i just have to there's no other
way and what's with
is is it i i my gut is telling me that i
need to shut the door
they are prowling
i heard steps to the right was that
something going to the right
oh i don't like how long i have to wait
okay i just have to be patient at the
door i can't panic
also i think in this one
this night
not that i will i think you could hold
the doors in this one
but it's not a good strategy you know
not that i've ever had
good strategies on any of this
i don't know i don't know what i'm doing
with the closet i don't know
they seem to be leaving me alone
god i'm getting my exercise in tonight
i'm freaking fleet footed
i just don't know
what
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i'm gonna assume i'm good there i'm
gonna i'm not even gonna check i'm not
gonna look i'm not even gonna look not
even gonna look
oh okay you do gotta wait you do gotta
wait
oh god
i like this zero
i don't know i don't know
okay
uncomfy uncomfy
uncomfy
say the line
say the line oh
i know what line you're talking about
in space with markiplier launches april
4th that's a monday
check out the trailer in the link in the
description below i know you guys love
that one i know you get
i know you guys love that one and i'm
here to deliver you know what
you you you walked up to me on the
street
and you go say the line i will say that
every time to you guys i'll say that
every time
don't you worry i got you covered i'll
say it again
space with markiplier launches april 4th
go check it out
go check out the trailer through the
link in the
description below
totally free
you're gonna love it
god guys
you're
you're embarrassing me
come on
oh say it again oh god i'll
later
later guys
anything for my adoring fans of course
i heard that
i i heard i heard that
say it all right guys
i can hear you
plier launches april 4th go check it out
the trailer
in the description below link is down
there
if you don't click it freddy's gonna be
in your closet you're gonna be the bite
of 22.
i don't know what the footsteps mean
oh
oh the other line oh oh the other line
ah
if you don't watch the trailer i'm gonna
put you in jailer
guys come on
you're too much you're too much guys
ah
you know
whatever i i love i love you guys i'll
say i'll i'll say whatever you want me
to say anytime any place
three days until the party after night
too god
that was legitimately terrifying
like
i know that's the whole point of these
games but i forgot just how
unsettling and i hesitate to say scary
this game actually was
he knows that you hate it here you're
right beside the exit if you run you can
make it
can i run
hurry run towards the exit well what if
i don't
no don't you remember what you saw the
exit is the other way hurry and leave
i don't remember oh god it's too late
hurry the other way and find someone who
will help you know what will happen if
he catches you i don't necessarily
you can find help if you get past him
you have to be strong
wait a minute crying child teeth
chomping action
this couldn't be what year is it
is it
april 4th 2022 when in space with
markiplier comes out not yet but in the
meantime you can watch the trailer
available through the link in the
description below go check it out if you
haven't already and if you have hey why
not check it out again just so you got
it in your brain when it's coming out
look forward to you seeing it
man i love that
it all pieced together i saw the
elements of it i saw it i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna get this
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get it i'm
not gonna get i'm gonna count to 20.
right at 40 i'm gonna write it 40
seconds i'm gonna slam this down and
it's gonna be boom right on the x
right at 40 seconds or we're gonna die
get ready to die or survive in
five
four
three
two
one ah oh interesting
hey
look at that
i did it and now i'm gonna waste my
advantage
god
like this video if you're shaking and
crying rn
oh was that the line you were talking
about oh
absolutely
stepping out there
i got a 2 am head start
i saw you
that's a problem with me playing these i
always talk
why why why
okay
okay
okay
hey
stop who stop don't
don't
i'm fine my headphones are gone
good oh good
[Music]
oh god i didn't mean to i didn't need to
i don't know what to do about hello
hello
okay that's not good
what was that
i think you shut the door and he starts
to calm down
isn't that the story of this one
this foxy
i heard stippy steps
okay
i gotta calm
go to sleep go to sleep watch the
trailer forks in space
i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die
when the light flickers is at them going
all right here steps to the left steps
to the left
there's also a little flicker
when i go there
and
you know there's a there's a little
flicker of the lights
oh my god i'm dead i'm so dead
oh hi be nice to me
huh
good
god
good god
that's actually got my heart going you
know not not gonna lie that actually got
my heart going
that was
that was intense
it's it's so fascinating to come back to
this game because i remember being very
frustrated with this game when i played
it but right now
maybe it's just because i'm on night
three i do see the fun in it right i do
see kind of like
the enjoyment you can have about it but
it's a little intense i i think what it
was is because over time the loud got
too much and it's just like i have to
listen loud and that'll drive anybody
crazy um
the longer they go so like i could
definitely see that i'm gonna keep going
i'm gonna finish this night for sure i
am extremely hungry i haven't eaten i
just want to like bite on something heck
i could bite 87 somethings right now if
you know what i'm talking about i'm that
hungry
anyway let's keep going
hey
i got it like i can already feel a bit
of a headache coming on just from like
the sheer sudden surge of blood pressure
to my brain
it's like an explosion
i freaking heard that what are you doing
oh
what are you doing
what do you what do you think you're
doing what are you doing
stop it
oh god
don't go
he really wants in there
i'm pretty sure it's holding that down
right oh god
that's what it is right
i think it is right
i don't know man
it is right
isn't it
it is it it totally is you got to hold
the door on them
i almost flashed
okay here footsteps i'm assuming the
footsteps means he's gone
gotta hold this door
flash first then close
oh flash for okay got it got it got it
understood understood
i don't think i ever did i know that
before
i don't know if i knew that before i
think that might be new news to me
hey
not hearing any footsteps out there
did i hear footsteps to the right
i might have heard footsteps
to the left left
nope i was wrong
okay so foxy is the real issue in this
one
what did i just hear
oh no oh oh no no no no no no no
what no that was
that was not what i thought it was was
it that that wasn't what i thought it
was
that was something else
but i thought there was something over
there
i knew it
okay i gotta get i gotta get foxy please
don't kill me don't go
[Music]
i hear that on the right oh my god i'm
dead i'm dead i'm so dead
okay i'm trusting that you're gone this
is a lot you know guys
i'm not gonna lie
there's a bit much
it's a bit much
okay
oh god that was on the right
oh my god i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead
i didn't hear it i didn't hear it
oh
jesus christ
jesus all right i'm going back in
i might be subjecting myself to the
repeated bites of 87
but uh
i heard that
[Music]
i do have to flashlight afterwards
foxy's not in yet
oh god
oh
god i thought i heard footsteps walking
away
no but foxy did not get in the room yet
that's the thing right
that's how it works foxy doesn't start
in the closet he gets in the closet
right he gets in the closet
all right i can beat this i know i can
beat this
i can definitely beat this
yeah so so if you don't let foxy in the
room he doesn't get in the room right
did i hear breathing was that breathing
what
the hell
what what what i'm sorry
i'm sorry excuse me
excuse me my excuse
what what happened i but i heard
breathing and i there and what
huh
right
i hear you
i'm flashing right away
cause i'm a big brave boy
i have to listen
i have to listen
okay that's not good
that's breathing
how do i know when he's gone
i don't know
how do i know
how am i supposed to know
oh god he's gonna get in
oh god i heard steps on the right left
i heard steph's on the left
[Music]
i'm telling you foxy's not in the closet
not yet anyway
look i'll i'll show you man
he's not there because i didn't let him
in yet
oh god i've lost foxy
oh no ah well he's gonna get in now
what
there he was told you that was foxy
told you
told you
even if i slightly suspect breathing i'm
gonna assume breathing
god damn it what the hell
what
the hell
i heard breathing
i heard stippy steps
how long i gotta hold that goddamn door
maybe i just gotta like count
there's probably like a certain amount
of time that i just gotta like count in
my head and that's what that is
all right we got this guys
we got this
what
hold on
fox is trying to tell me something
there's a trailer
for an upcoming
show
in space
with
hang on
markiplier wow
who would have thought and where is the
foxy where is it
in the link in the description
he's really giving me the secrets
he's really giving me the secrets
thank you foxy
i really appreciate that where are you
what oh i heard that
okay just a lot of this
a lot of this
heard something right here
yep okay ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
okay that was excessive
oh god he got in oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
hi
are
you oh
foxy can you please calm down oh my god
there's someone to the right
one
two
three
four
five six
seven
eight
okay i gotta get foxy gotta get foxy
okay i gotta check left i gotta check
left
and i gotta get the bears
get out of here get out of here get out
of here
foxy please don't kill me
i heard something about the right
okay
one
two
three
four
five
six
oh i don't know i i swear i can't rely
on the sounds because i don't know well
know him well enough
okay 3am
manageable
oh hey oh oh
hey
hi
okay so
the trick is
does
when not letting foxy and i don't know
could could not whatever
does
when you turn around
the sound reverse so if i'm this way but
i'm looking that way
technically speaking the right would be
left and left would be right in this
game does the sound flip when you turn
around because logically
that makes sense but
it's an important detail you know what i
mean
i don't think it would but who knows
i have no idea
oh god where am i
hmm
oh god
okay
i just can't let foxy in i can't
i must not
oh god wait
but
come back here come back here
okay we're good we're okay
i think it does
wait
maybe it doesn't
okay
foxy where are you
i don't know where he is i gotta check
this
oh don't know
oh god he's in okay well we're in
trouble now guys
i hear you on the right there i'm going
for it i'm going for it i just gotta go
i heard it
i don't i don't know what i'm doing guys
i don't know
well i don't know what i'm doing
apparently
this game
this game
this game man
it's tough i'm trying to do
so
what i'm doing is i'm not trying i'm not
playing how i could potentially play
which is just follow every sound
even the ones that aren't foxy i'm
trying to play in a way where
you have
this opportunity to not let foxy in the
room which i think if i remember the
hardest mode of this was trying to put
off
getting foxy in the room as long as
possible like that was the key to it
that was the crux of it and if you could
do that then you'd have a more
better chance to survive down the road
this was hard though
that's hard
all right
let me try this again
i know
i can get this one
i heard that
yeah i did hear that
i hear steps on the way i'm trusting
that that
oh god damn it he's in how did you get
in already
all right whatever
oh he didn't wait what
what what's happening
what's happening
what
i don't know
oh god what is it oh no i'm dead i'm
dead
so dead i'm so dead
what was the sound
i don't what was the sound
oh god i just heard that
oh my god i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm
dead i'm dead i'm so dead
i'm not dead apparently
i do i i don't
hey stop that
what's going on
i hear
nothing i don't know
okay
okay epoxy is still not in the closet
somehow
i think someone's there
i think
nope okay
hey
i don't know i don't know i don't know
it's weird
this is a weird one
i can hear you [ __ ]
which way they go
oh god
heard that
i heard that
definitely heard that
i think the flicker might be at the tel
oh god i didn't mean to do that oh god
i'm dead
oh god
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i'm dead i'm dead i'm so dead oh did he
get in i don't know
i apparently not
oh god
oh god
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay we're fine apparently
where did that go i don't
okay
because sworn i heard breathing but it
wasn't
that was a lie
no
he's still there
i hear that on the right
i hear that
yep
not today buddy not today not today
buddy
[Music]
no
[Applause]
i
i thought i heard i both i heard one set
of footsteps beforehand and i was like
that's foxy
and then i heard another set of
footsteps i was like okay
that means clear right
damn
well
this game is hard
i gotta say
five nights at freddy's 4 is definitely
the most stressful so far besides super
hard mode five nights at freddy's 2 it's
definitely the most stressful it keeps
your your nerves going
it keeps like this anticipation flowing
like
i don't recall it being this terrifying
all i
[Music]
oh i gotta listen for the breathing
again
i don't open oh that was it
ah
okay
right
that makes more sense
that makes more sense
ah that makes more sense
all right let's give this one more try
let's do this one more time i kept foxy
out of that the whole time
it i kept foxy out of that the whole
time so it's totally possible you just
gotta like lean with him
wherever he goes
what oh god damn it
god
damn it okay
hang on i'm gonna just
oh he didn't get in what
what wait i'm so confused
i'm so confused i thought he got in
i thought he did
apparently not
he's still out there
huh
there he is
he's out there
i hear you
there's a fake breathing it's not real
breathing
there he is peekaboo
ah
damn it i don't know which way he went
i hear you
so i gotta wait
okay that that's much more helpful
i get it now
i totally get it now
damn it oh he got in god damn it
well [ __ ]
god
[Music]
alright then
all right ben well
that's all the time i got
unfortunately
i guess
i'll just have to leave this one live
back in 2015. good god that was that
long ago if you want to see the rest of
this that i played way back in the day
when i was actually good at these games
you can uh look at my five nights at
freddy's playlist unfortunately i gotta
go uh unfortunately i gotta go i am out
of time i'm actually like real talk i'm
legitimately incredibly busy preparing
for the launch of in space with
markiplier it's literally all i've been
doing
uh so
i really truly mean it
when i say
i really hope you enjoy it it's been a
labor of love
for the past like two years
i've been working on this one project
and obviously i've been working on other
projects but the reason i talk about it
so much is because i am so incredibly
proud of it and i'm so incredibly proud
of all the people that have put their
faith in me
and uh made this
idea of mine come to life
it does come out
april 4th
2022
which is
very soon it is
alarmingly soon
if you have not seen the trailer and i
know i've been pushing it very hard but
i really truly honestly think you'll
enjoy it there's a link in the
description it'll take you to the
trailer it's two minutes
all i like i've been streaming for an
hour and five all i ask is that if you
haven't seen it check it out i think
you'll enjoy it
i mean i i think at this point for as
long as you know me
you can trust when i say i will actually
thank you and i actually think you will
enjoy something and i mean it from the
bottom of my heart when the show comes
out it is totally free i made this all
for you
i legitimately poured my heart and soul
into this project for you because i know
you'll enjoy it
so check out the trailer links in the
description thank you everyone so much
for watching
and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye bye guys i gotta go i'm starving
i haven't eaten all day and it is
currently 7 27
that's how busy i've been
so i'm gonna go have dinner all right
have a good night everybody link in the
description thank you
farewell